as spring slowly descends on us the
automotive scene descends on Geneva
eager to see what the year will bring at
center stage for Porsche this time
around our two products of its endurance
racing program the 309 kilowatt 911 rsr
is a further evolution of the road-going
911 which scooped a one-two finish in
its class at LeMond last year
the all-new 919 hybrid will be
challenging in the top-tier LM p1 class
at Lamar with a downsized displacement
of two leaders the four-cylinder
turbocharged engine generates a whopping
368 kilowatts of power
question Portia has decided to rejoin
the world endurance championship and the
lmp1 claps explained CEO Matthias
Mueller hence the presentation of the
new 919 hybrid and the 911 rsr here he's
very happy with their development and
hopes they'll provide some stiff
competition in stocking cagna up kaden
cunnin opal has plumped for the flashy
rather than the furious giving the Adam
rocks convertible its debut the latest
addition to the atom family is an urban
mini crossover with a 15 millimeter
raised ride height and rugged outdoor
style body cladding
the electrically operated canvas roof
can be retracted in just 5 seconds and
has a neoprene cover for weather
proofing see up presents the top hot
hatch from the Leon family the Cupra
available for the first time as a 3 door
coupe a the new model is powered by a
choice of 22 litre engines delivering up
to 206 kilowatts it's Pepe around town
fiery down the freeway and cool as you
like on country roads all at the touch
of a button the driver can switch the
coopers character between comfortable
sporty and dynamic
BMW is out to tackle new terrain with
the 2 Series active tourer this is the
first front-wheel drive model to bear
the BMW batch it's also the brand's
first mpv with a flexible interior
configuration catering to families this
is a new concept segment for BMW
explains Development Director have a DS
it has an elevated seat position and
high spatial functionality but also with
fun at the wheel galore in distance
equipped I'm more familiar territory for
BMW the new Ford or 4-series grancoupe a
derived from the two-door 4 series coupe
a
meanwhile over at many the club man
concept provides a sneak preview of the
upcoming generation the new audition has
grown significantly in length
lexis graces the European stage with its
first glimpse of the new RCF Kupe the
new 5-liter v8 powerplant promises in
excess of 300 30 kilowatts making it the
most powerful engine ever to feature in
a production lexus especially calibrated
8-speed automatic transmission ensures
optimum power delivery right up to the
red line
another monster of horsepower on show is
the Bentley Continental GT Speed now in
both Kupe and convertible form it comes
with spoilers and side skirts color
match to the body less inconspicuous are
the red painted brake calipers behind
the alloy wheels this latest Bentley is
fitted with a specially tuned 6-liter
engine with twin turbo w12 power
howdy is celebrating the world premiere
of the third generation TT when the
original TT was launched 16 years ago it
was quickly deemed a design revolution
this latest edition sees that bull
designed vocabulary revisited and
reinvented the cockpit and its control
and display concept however is all new
it is this is the icon created by Audi
stresses the brand's development chief
and embodies out a sporting signs are
there all eyes at the Toyota stand were
on a compact and practical number this
time the ex theme is spelled out large
indeed when it comes to the front design
of the new I go the redesigned city
slicker also has a wide range of
equipment options every detail of the I
go whether in form or function has been
geared up for maximum driver delight
the high-contrast designed with its
splashes and swooshes of shiny black are
clearly aimed at younger car buyers
mazda is likewise in town to present a
world first the hasumi concept car a
realistic look ahead to future models
showcasing skyactiv technology and Kodo
design azumi means bound or spring up in
japanese the new subcompact can be
considered the blueprint for Mazdas next
generation of small cars
another premier the T rock from
Volkswagen this gulf-based concept car
combines the talents of an all-wheel
drive SUV with a summary airiness of a
convertible the middle section of the
roof comprises two halves that can be
taken off and stowed in the trunk in no
time at all
there are 0 the tee ruk was designed to
win over new target groups explains
powertrain head hines jakub noisy
especially young people it has a very
emotional design very progressive
styling and crucially the car has a very
sculptural character the spots a cotton
easiest cooked alive character the form
vocabulary of the dynamic but dashing
vision SI coupe a sees scooter
introducing the next evolutionary step
in its design language the outward
appearances markedly sporty-er edgier
and more emotional under the hood is a
bible and 1.4 liter TSI engine that
works with gasoline or natural gas the
5-door vision c is already compliant
with the european union's 2020 emission
standards with an excellent co2 value of
91 g/km another Kupe i'll be at the
two-door variety is the star of the
Mercedes show the new s-class coupe a is
big without being overbearing elegant
but not outdated and also comes packed
with a very latest technology the
combination of hard and soft edges adds
to the dynamic look like so many of the
models debuted in geneva the s-class
coupe a will be hitting the streets in a
very near future
you